ونحييكم الى التفاصيل ونقاش الملف الاول
تواصل تركيا استيعابه حجمي كارثه الزلزال
التي تعيشها منذ اسبوعين وسط تبادل
الاتهامات التقصير بين الحكومه والمعارضه
التركيه ما يجعل من هذه الازمه ورقه مهمه
في الانتخابات المرتقبه احزاب المعارضه
التركيه تواصل توجيه الانتقادات لسياسه
الحكومه في التعاطي مع الزلزال تؤكد ان
حجم الكارثه اظهر عجزا في التعاطي الحكومي
معها فوفق تقرير نشرت وكاله قال احد زعماء
المعارضه ان تراكم السلطه السياسيه بيد
اردوغان وضعف الاستجابه السريعه اعاقه
جهود الانقاذ وباتت السلطات اقل كفاءه من
جديد غير ان الحكومه ردتها تصريحات
الاحزاب المعارضه بغير اللائقه داعيه
لتضافر كافه الجهود ومشيره الى ان اردوغان
اقر ببطء الاستجابه سلوى ان تحقيقا سيفتح
لمعرفه الاسباب جو مشحون بالتوترات
السياسيه وحتى الاقتصاديه ينظر بانتخابات
صعبه على الطرفين خصوصا اذا توافقت
المعارضه ونجحت بتقديم المرشح مشترك
لمنافسه اردوغان وفق مراقبين اكدت مصادر
رسميه ووسائل اعلام تركيا انه لا توجد
حاليا اي امكانيات لتاجيل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في تركيا الى ما بعد
14 من مايو
[موسيقى]
زلزال تركيا المدمر يخلط اوراق الحكومه
التركيه
[موسيقى]
زلزال يخلف عشرات الالاف من القتلى
والمصابين ودمار واسع في كل مكان
[موسيقى]
السلطات التركيه صرعت الارسال فرق الانقاذ
والاغاثه
اعلان حال الطوارئ ثلاثه اشهر
اعتقالات طالت مقاولي بنا
لكن ارتفاع عدد ضحايا الزلزال زاد من
الغضب الشعبي
وسط اتهامات بتاخر عمليه البحث والانقاذ
[موسيقى]
تصاعد الانتقادات دفع اردوون الى الاقرار
بالتقصير ووجود ثغرات في الاستجابه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من انقره بركات
قاره المحلله السياسي اهلا بك من اسطنبول
الدكتور بكير اتوجان مديره معهد اسطنبول
للفكر اهلا بكم ضيوفي واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من اسطنبول معك دكتور بكير دكتور بكير في
الواقع تطرح هذه الازمه العديد من
التساؤلات وخلينا نبدا كيف تبع الكل
المجتمع الدولي بالاساس
كما يتحدث عن وجوب ان يلتزم الكل بانسانيه
هذه الازمه الا ان المناكفات السياسيه اتت
من الداخل اتت من تركيا في وقت مبكر بين
المعارضه والحكومه والبعض قال بانه هذه
الازمه مع الاسف وصفها بانها مفتاح
الانتخابات القادمه يبقى السؤال لصالح من
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم يعني اولا لابد
الاشاره ونقطه ذكرتموها كنت اريد ان ابدا
بها ولكن السؤال جاءت في نفس النقطه منذ
البدايه
لاحظنا هناك تضامن من دول العالم والتعاون
وحتى حتى هذا التعاون والتضامن جاءت من
الدول على سبيل المثال اليونان اليونان
الى الى اليوم هناك تصريحات
ويعني غير محتمله كانت ان ياتي وزير
الخارجيه خاصه
الذي كان مازال يصرح ضد تركيا بشكل
كبير جدا واحتمال الوقوع
حرب بين اليونان وتركيا في كل لحظه وخاصه
الشهر القادم ايضا هذه الاحتمال تزيد الى
99%
وقوع حرب بين الدولتين
بسبب الخلافات القديمه والجديده ولكن نجد
حتى اليونان تضامنت وكانت هناك زيارات
وحتى مع وزير خارجيه اليوناني مع الوزير
الخارجيه ولهذا قلت بان المجتمع الدولي
والكل في الواقع طبعا انا مع هذه الازمه
ولكن داخل التركي هذه يعني هذه الاسئله
التي تطرح لاستفهامات التي تطرح بين
المعارضه والحكومه ولكن نقطه لابد ذكرها
لابد ذكرها للاسف الشديد احزاب المعارضه
كلها بدلا من ان تتضامن مع الشعب بدلا ان
تكون تعاون حتى مع الحكومه لان هذه عندما
كانت هناك يعني
كما وجدنا في بعض الزلزال هناك تبرعات
لصالح هؤلاء
المؤثرين من الزلزال كانت بجميع اطياف
الشعب لكن المعارضه كانت خارج اللعبه
تماما وخاصه زعماء المعارضه وهذه النقطه
سلبيه لن يعني لن تغفر لهم لا اليوم ولا
في المستقبل وانا
يعني من الان ادعي بان هذه المعارضه سوف
تفشل في الانتخابات المقبله التي سوف
المعارضه وانتقاداتها للحكومه ستكلفها
الكثير في الانتخابات القادمه خلينا نسمع
راي الاستاذ بركات في هذا الموضوع عفوا
ليس انتقادات هذا الانتقاد واجب هذا
الانتقاد شرط هناك تقصيرات من الحكومه
ولكن ولكن كانت عليهم ان
يفعلوا ذلك بعد على الاقل ليس من منذ
اللحظه الاولى ليس من اليوم الاول والثاني
والثاني
ولكن خلينا خلي ضيفنا يشارك معنا استاذ
بركات هل تعتقد بان هذه التصريحات هذه
المتبادله في الواقع من الطرفين معارضا
انتقدت الحكومه بانها لم تتحمل مسؤوليه
هذا وهذه الازمه
بالطريقه او بالمستوى الذي كان ينتظر من
البعض فيما الحكومه تقول بان المعارضه
تركت الجانب الانساني وسارعت في بدء طرح
حسابات سياسيه هل تعتقد كما يقول دكتور
بكير بان هذه الانتقادات ستكلف المعارضه
الكثير
مساء الخير
بالحقيقه
ما حصل كان واضح تماما تقصير بالتدخل
الصريع للحكومه بكل الاماكن وهذا لم ياتي
من خلال تحليلات هذه معطيات واضحه من من
الساحات التي
والصراخ التي اتى من الجماهير بحد ذات
نفسه يعني الاحزاب اللي يتحدث عنها ضيفك
لازال لا زالت بالحقيقه في الميادين الى
جانب الشعب
ولازلت تقوم بدورها وربما
يعني ممكن اقول لك بتاريخ تركيا لم يحصل
ما حصل من تضامن وتعاون بالحقيقه التي سبق
الحكومه
كل هذه
الانقاذ والفرق التي قدمت وفي العون
والتضامن لذلك الان لا شك لمين عندما يصير
تقصير وعندما يصير تخلف بالتدخل لبعد
يومين من من الزلزال مين المسؤول عن هذه
التاخير اليس الحكومه بحد ذاتها صحيح هنا
يعني انا لا اقول بانه والله الحكومه ما
عملت شيء ولا قدمت شيء طبعا قدمت لكن
للاسف الشديد ليس على المستوى المطلوب
لانه في انا شخصيا عائلتي واقربائي
ومدينتي انطاكيا هاتاي كلها يعني باليوم
الثالث حتى توصلت الفرق الانقاز لهذه
المناطق يعني هذا واضح ولاح
يعني كتير من من الناس التي توفوا هم
نتيجه هذه التقصير وهذا التدخل المتاخر
انا بتقديري ما حصل بانه امتحان كان كبير
بالنسبه للسلطه هذه هو سؤال الاستاذ
ستدفع ثمنه
في الانتخابات نعم ستدفع ثمنه في
الانتخابات القادمه لا بد منه لانه الشعب
واعي على كل ما حصل في تركيا اتصور يعني
وصلت الفرق من من انحاء العالم في اليوم
الثاني بينما تركيا للاسف الشديد لم تصل
الحكومه
بفرق انقاذها لليوم الثالث الواقع استاذ
حتى يطرح اسئله صحيح ولكن البعض كذلك يطرح
حتى اسئله ليس بخصوص التاخر ليس بخصوص
ازمه تويتر كذلك التي كانت حاضره في اولى
ايام هذه الازمه ولكن حتى فيما يخص
الاعتقالات التي تبعنا تفاصيلها وهنا سؤال
دكتور بكير ضيف يقول بان هذه الحكومه يجب
ان تتحمل مسؤوليتها ولم تتحمل حتى الان
ونحن تبعنا الاعتقالات هذه الاعتقالات
طالت مقاولين البعض يقول بانه هل المقاول
هو الوحيد الذي علي تحمل المسؤوليه لان
البناء ليس مقاول فقط البناء تربه البناء
ارض ونحن تبعنا بان هناك بنايات لما سقطت
شهود عيان وثقوا تربه غير مؤهله لان تبنى
فيما بعد هناك كذلك رخص تؤخذ من البلديات
وهناك كذلك وثائق تؤخذ من مديريه المسح
العقاري وغرف المعماريين لماذا لم نرى
التحمل مسؤوليه كامل لكل الاطراف
قبل الاجابه على سؤالك اريد ان اتطرق الى
نقطه مهمه انا للاسف الشديد عشت الزلزال
1999 في اسطنبول وفي يلا وفي مدينه التي
كانت بالقرب من بعضهما وكنت يعني
منذ قبلها وبعدها اثناء هذا الزلزال الذي
حصل ومن المتاثرين جدا جدا فيها وفي هذا
الزلزال للاسف الشديد خسرت اقربائي مقربين
واصدقائي للاسف الشديد
وانا متاثر ما زلت متاثرا على ما حصل ولكن
لست من باب الدفاع عن الحكومه بكير
الموضوع مؤثر للجميع حتى من لم يعيش زلزال
99 والذي تابع كثيرا ازمه انسانيه كبيره
جدا وتعزينا الحاره لك ولكل الاتراك في
الواقع وكل السوريين
فهذا فهذا السبب
اعتقد الحكومه
هذه كانت اردوغان خاصه كان في رئاسه
البلديه 1999 في اسطنبول وعاش الازمه
ويعرف الازمه جيدا والان يعرف ويدري
الازمه اكثر مما كانت 99 لانها 99 كانت
مقارنه ما حصل للاسف الشديد صغيره يعني
استطعم من حيث الشده من حيث المدن التي
اصابت هذا الزلزال وحتى الجغرافيا وحتى
عدد الضحايا للاسف الشديد وحتى التنظيم
وما حصل بعدها وقبلها اذا قارن اثنين لا
اريد ان ادخل في تفاصيل الاثنين ولكن كما
اشرت في سؤالك نعم هناك ليس فقط متاهدين
هناك مهندسين هناك رؤساء بلديه هناك يعني
مسؤولين اخرين سوف يحاسبون على ما حصل في
هذا الزلزال من اهمال طبيعي وايضا الحكومه
ايضا ايضا تسال لماذا لان هناك قوانين لن
تطبق فالحكومه مسؤوله عن تطبيق هذه
القوانين نعم قوانين صارمه بالنسبه
للزلزال ولكن للاسف في هذه المدن لن تطبق
ليست للمره الاولى لن تطبق هذه حصلت في
عده مدن ولو كانت على مستوى صغير جدا في
السنوات الماضيه ولكن انا واثق نحن عندما
نتكلم لا اريد ان اقول بان الحكومه ليست
لها علاقه لا بالعكس الحكومه مسؤوله وهي
تجب على الشعب ان تسال هذه الحكومه ولكن
للاسف الشديد المعارضه تجب عليها ان تقدم
شيئا ولكن حتى على الاقل تضامن وتعاون مع
الشعب نجد بان المسؤولين المعرض ذهبوا الى
الميدون كلها
وكلهم حاولوا بدلا ان يتضامنوا
يعني نفسيا
اخلاقيا الى جانب هؤلاء
الذين تاثروا بالزلزال حولوها الى كيف
تستفيدون منها من الناحيه السياسيه نحن
ننتقل
ونحن الان يجب علينا ان نبقى عن هذه
السياسه ولو لفتره واعطيت مثالا رئيس وزير
الخارجيه اليوناني ماذا فعل علما بانه
الان يريد الحرب الكل تضامن مع الجانب
التركي لكن نحن
الكبير خلينا فقط يشارك معنا لانك قاربت
حضرتك بين زلزال 99 وهذا الزلزال واعتبرت
بان اردوغان كذلك قدم وكان حاضر في هذه
الازمه بما يمكن ان يشفع له ما رايك استاذ
بركات
عزيزي الكريمه يعني بانه في هذه الزلزال
بهذه الفتره اول شيء يجب علينا ان نعرف
بانها الذهنيه اداره البلد من مركز واحد
ومن شخص واحد سقطت سقطت بالمره
البروقراطيه الان البروقراطيه لعبه دورا
كبيرا فعلا بالوفيات وفي ازدياده الوفيات
اتصوري يعني بعد 13 يوم اذا كان هناك بعد
الناس انقذت باحياء اصبح يعني هنا في
تاخير لرفع هذه الانقاض والوصول على ولكن
نعم ولكن هل تنكر حضرتك بان الرئيس
اردوغان كان حاظر كان حاضر في كل
المؤتمرات كان محاط بافراد الحكومه هل
تعتقد بان هذا الموضوع قادر عزيز يمر
للشعب ان يطرح على الشعب بطريقه قد تكون
ايجابيه للحكومه او ان الفعل هو الذي
سيغلب على هذه الصوره اتفضل
صديقتي لا يكفي بالزياره بانه ب 700 على
الاقل امني الى مدينه من مدينه لمدينه فقط
والتصريح والرجوع الى البلد هناك
الوسائل الفرق في الميادين كانت تنتظر
القرارات من المركز
وصدقيني عشرات الاماكن عشرات الاماكن كان
الصراخ من تحت الانقاض لا احد يتدخل فيها
لانه هون ما في هون اوامر من المركز وهنا
المسؤول الاساسي الحكومه بحت ذات وهذه
النظام الرئاسي بحد ذاته ولاحظت الان يعني
صحيح تمت اعتقالات في 2030 شخص ولكن هل
هذا يكفي لماذا لم يستقيل اي وزير مثلا من
هذه الحكومه او من المسؤولين عن هذه
التقصير قانونيا وتنفيذيا ومتابعه لم يست
شخص واحد يعني لذلك اصبح
بعد المقاولين فقط والمهندسين هذا لا هذه
نقطه ستبقى المتابعه
بالحقيقه هذه القوى على كل هذه النقاط
ستبقى للمتابعه كانت هذه اول مصافحه لطرح
موضوع سياسي
دكتور تفضل
يعني ضيفك يشكر بان الان حكم الشخص الواحد
99 كانت هناك ثلاثه احزاب مشاركه في الحكم
وللاسف الشديد نعم انا لا اريد ان اقول
الان للاسف الشديد حتى اليوم اتصلوا معي
بعض اقربائي من المدن التي وقعت فيها
الزلزال لم يستطيع الحصول على الخيم حتى
يعني انا اقول تقصير كبير نعم موجود
ومازال موجود ولكن في 99 لا احد يعني لا
لن يكون احدا موجود وهناك ثلاثه احزاب
مشاركه في الحكومه ودارت الازمه 99 ولا
احد موجود على الساحه على الاقل هنا ناس
موجودين نعم لا يلبون ولكن موجودين بعض
الناس المسؤولين هناك لا يوجد احد لذلك
اذا عادت هذه الصيغه نفسها حكومه سته
احزاب سبعه احزاب من احزاب اذا اذا حصل
زلزال بهذا الحجم سوف
كارثه ليست في تركيا كارثه عالميه ربما
تكون على مستوى ليست مضحكه
ولكن هناك نقاط كبيره للنقاش وهذه مصافحه
اولى لفتح المجال السياسي
لانه كما تبعت كنا التزمنا بالازمه
السياسيه بالازمه الانسانيه فقط دون طرح
مواضيع او نقاط سياسيه كانت هذه اول
مصافحه والاكيد باننا سنعود لمتابعه كل
هذه التفاصيل شكرا جزيلا على الحضور
والمشاركه من اسطنبول دكتور بكير اتجان
مدير معهد اسطنبول الفكر ومن انقره بركه
قار المحلله السياسي شكرا لكم